welcome to this video playing I'm
asesino get snowed in Turkey no name
yeah they don't have so many GM's in
Turkey I don't know whether this though
let's see an Italian game playing is
solid modern line with a six Bishop a
seven and so on
yeah he's delaying castles yeah I think
I can go with d5 yeah actually if he
delays that just complete development
maybe you can take here actually okay
well if he takes only five I just have
to just have to try to claim
compensation which I might have or maybe
not
okay so Queen d5
you can also check on e5 with a knight
isn't this good with a check on d3
coming
Queenie five rupee eight wins so and
Bishop c4 I mean there's also beehive or
rook e8 e8 let the stop look at forward
ya know it's maybe a little bit late to
think I'm the ship's chief although sb5
winning really be five
b5f FOIA those kind of moves they could
be could be tricky
it is good though maybe I should just
play it and don't think about it for
ages
I can also just yeah I mean I can just
play 9 to 6 cm double-checking
c4 I have four to two pieces hanging
okay so lets me keep the pawn Knight to
d5 if is a good plan and one good plan
threatening Knight takes c3 Knight c3
takes Queenie be one chick rock-beetle
check King it's not it's not direct win
but okay I mean I'm just a piss-up it's
no no reason to do anything fancy
okay so by now I probably should should
calculate this for once hmm
but there is no no chick made available
directly
or here for Queenie foil it's also good
night a5 Queenie for threatening night
b3 check made that's not bad anyway
that's let's go here and I'd be three
mate that's quite quite a threat
check okay
Jerris butcher pianets I'm really not
playing you see threatening anything
here at all I mean I can also give this
chick here
yeah okay is this a really city bishop
Yaya let's make let's see that this is
that it is doing something 96 I take D
phone I just want to break through him
check white reasons Jam
that was a wasn't off game for white
yeah I don't know about all that here
especially six so bad I mean probably
castles is better but not sure if this
is so great for white I'm two castles I
mean I have some development what's
clear is that what he played is not
working and this is definitely not good
when G for a d4 seems to at least them
continue the game and 97 for this yeah
that that that's so quite decent for
white I'm better but it's nothing so so
terrible
I have better pieces this is not not
very well coordinated have things like
that to come but it's not the total the
total destruction that that happened to
him he was just a porn down and
lost position yeah I didn't play them in
the quickest way right okay what can you
do a piece up and in a check don't need
to be super precise to still win okay
well thanks for watching